Greg: TT IS TRUE!
HAPPY WEDNESDAY,VERYDY.
HUH?
YEAH
I ST WT TO TAKALL OF Y HOME AND.
TONIGHT I CE AGAIN WANTO
TALKBOUT MY PILEALL
RTNER AND TWITR CEO ON
MUSK
SOS YOU KNOW HE ST FIRED
ME DUDE NAMED JIM BAKER.
I OW THERE'S LE HUNDRED
JIM BAKERS.
NOT INCLUDING ONESHO CK
PIE IN A STADIUM.
THANK YOU.
GYM BAKER.
ALL RIT,OU'RE ALL JERKS.THIS JIS
PUTYENERAL CNCIL W H
ALLEDLY SUPPRESSEDNTERL
DOCUMES ABOUT EXPRESNG THE
BIN PTOP SRY
S, HE WAS APPARENTLY
PRESNG THE NEWS ABOUT THE PREVI.
TH'S LOTF PPREION.
WORSE AN SHARING A HOTUB
AFTEEATING ACHIPLE
SUPPRESSION.
YOKNOW WHAT I ME?
HUH?
U DO
BUNOW HE JUST GOT SUPPRESSED.
MUSKWEET THAIN LIGHT OF
CONCER ABOUT BER'S POSSIE
LE ISUPPRESSION OFINFORMATN HE
ITTETODAY.
EXITED.I LOVEHAT.
IT LIKE TTING FIRED BUT WITH
A TRAP DOOR THAT DPS YOU
STIGHT INTO A WELL FULL
POOP.THAT'S MY DRM.
THIS ITHE ME JIMAKER THE FORMER
LPED PUSH THE EELE DOSSI
AX.
JIM COMEY'S LEL COSEL.
BUT IF YOUISTEN TO T MIA
YOU THINK EL JT LAIDFF A 68EAR E
IRED CLEANING DY WH A PROSTHET E
LUNG CANCER.
T OUT OF HKERR TRUED AND
TAKE YR OXEN TANK WI YOU.
IT'S TRUNOW, MUSK IS SUSPICIS TL
FORE MATT TAIBBI UNVEILETHEM
FRAY KEEPING THEBI'S NE
T OF EVERYTHING.
YOHAVE TO WONDER HOW A FORR
FBI  YOUR CENSOR LIKHAVING A
FOX  YR CHICKECOOP HEAD
COUN
SOUSK IS LIKE OUEARS,
FINALLY MEBOOT JT
TALKG ABOUT EE SECH BUT
DEFENDING IT.
CE AIN IT'ALABOUT TRANS
PATTERNS SOMHING OUR MEDIAHATES
DOESIAPERASH.
AND WHILE THMEDIA  BUSY BITCHIN
EMPLOYE HAVING TO GETOBS WHEREE
MASSSE, MUSK HAS BN BUSY TACKLI
ON.
CHILD PORN.
IT'SEEN PROBLEM  THE PLATFORMORS
EN LONGER THAN DANA'S
LENTSS PICTURES OF DOGS.
JUSTAST YEARLONE, THERWERE
NEAR 87,000 RERTOF CHILD EXPLOI
THAT PROBLEM, RIGHT?
THERS NOENOUGH SUNLIGHT IN
THE UNIVER TO SINFT THAT
DDLE OF PRAVT BUT UNDER SK
HE INSUBSTITUTING A ZERO
TOLENCE LICYHICH SHOULD BE
THE POCY FOR ERY PLATFORM
PEON AND FANCYANDBAGAKER
OVER T PAST FEW WES
CYBERSURITEXPERT HAS BEE
WORKG ALONGSIDE TWITTER'S
VAMPED TRUST A SETY TE
TOETECT ABUSE CONTENT AT
FAER MORE FICIENT ANMORE
AGESSI SPEED A I F ONE
CAN'T IT TDO THEEDIA
ITICISM OF THI
SO WT IF YOU'RE OPPING CHILDPOR.
YOU SHOULD BE ASHAD
YOURLF.
SO FARHE SUSNSION RATE ON ACCOU
S DOLED AND I N HEAR THE
LEFTIES NOYEAH, THAT'S GAT BUT
COUNWITH THE HANDLE
T'R-NE 66 JU MISNDERED
ADMIRAL VINE.WHAT AREOUOING TO ?
44,000 ACCOUS WERE TAKEN DN
INCLUDG MANY THAT IED TO
BYSS DETECTIONSING CODE
WORDS AND HER TRICKS.
AGAIN THAT IN A SILE DAY.
COMPARIIT TOOK OVER MONTH FOR
57,0IMILAR ACCOUS IN
INDI
SOE'S DONE MORE GOOD IN E LAST D
DC POLLS HE EVER DONEMENT AND
DON'T FORGE'S AFRICAN
AMERICAN
SOAFRICASO UNDERUSK, I'T IT TRUE
THATWITTERAS DONE MORE TO
STOP CHILD EXPLOATION IN T
ST MONTHHAN PROBAB THE LAST 10 ?
>> IT TRUE, YES
TWITTEHAS DONE ME  STO
CHILD EXPLOITION IN PROBABLY
THE ST MDAY THANROBABLY
THLAST TEN YEARS.>> Greg: YES.A
AND WE SHOULPOINT OUTHAT THE
ADE OFHILD PN WAS LL
KNOWN.
TWITTER WAEVEN SUED OVER IT.
WHICH MAKES IT AMAZING THAT TH
DIA LOOKS AT THERE MUSK
PERIOD AS THE GOODLD DAYS.
THAT'S LIKE AGGI ABOUT YR
FREQUENT FLY MILES FROM
FFREY EPSTN'S JE
'S WEIRD.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VEEEN ON
ITTER LATELY BUT IBETTER
IF YOUGNORTHE MEDIA WHO CUT
AND PASTTWEE THE SRMIN
TS ARE GONTHERE ARFEWER HATE TW
THAT IARE EXCEPT WWERE TOLD
THAT TT WOULD GET WOAND IT
DIDN'T.SURPRISEANOTHER E FR THEN
AND T ANHER LIE FROMHIS
CLOW
>> TTTER IS CINGERY REAL AND VET
THE RING VOLUME OF AER,
HATEAND TI-SEMITISM  THEIRPLATF
PPEN.
>>reg: HMM.
SHS THE ON ONE W CAN MAKE
BRN LLIAMS GRIPE THAT E
STTCHETHE TRUTH.
SHE LIES MORE AN IIDHIFF
DATING.
SO DAY WE'LL OPEN HEBIERS
AND E TH WERE FILLED WCOMIC BOOK
GOT LE HATE SS CHILD
PLOITION.
THAT SMS LE AN IMPROVEMENTISN'T
ULD BE FOR
INSTD LIBERALS COMAIN THAT
REPUBLICANCARE T MUCH ABOU
SUHINGS.NEXT THEY'LL SAY FHTINGL
EXPLOITATI IS WHITE SUPREMACY,I.
[CHES ANAPPLAUSE].
ERIOD!
>> Gg: L'SELCOME TONIGHT
GUES!
SHE'S ALL OUGH TBE A
STOCKING STUER.
HOST OF ERICS NEWSOOM
AND E FIVE, DANA PINO!
HEERS AND APPLSE]
>>reg:WRITES F MAJ
PUBLICATIO, TH DELIVERS TH
HIS PER RT.
HOST OF E GUY BEON SHOW, GBENSO!
[CERS AND APPLAU].
>> Gre HER MISTLETOE HAS A
BUNIONFOX NEWS CONTRIBUTORAT TP.
[CHES AND APPLAUSE>> Greg: AND
COIES FOR CHRISTS.
MY MASSIVE SE KICK AND T
NWA'WORLD HEAVY IGHT
CHAMPION TYR!
HEERS AND APPLSE]
>> Gg: ISN'T IT INRESTG WE
WERE TALNG ABOUT TON THE
FI DAN THAT'S A SHOW YOU ANDI B.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Da: 1YEARS ING.
>> Gre IF WASN'T FOR US
THATHING WOULD BUNDER WATER.
OH,  GOD
N'T WORRY, THEY DON'T WATCH.
BU NO, IT'S LIKE, AGAIN, TS
AEXAMPLE OF HOWHE MEDIA
STRIS AGNST CERTAISHOW
CERTAIN IDEA THEY N'DO
CERTAIN TOPI, T EY'LL DO
OTHERS.I DON'T THINK VE SEEN A
ABOUT THIS CLD ELOITATION STUFF.
SOT'S LIKE THEY'RE LE WEE
SCABS FOR VERI THIS STORY.
>> Da: A ALSO U'RE
CREANG A DISACTION
THIS ITHEIR FAVORITE THI TO SAYG
THE ITTEFILE THATHIS IS A DISTR.
I LO THEHREAD ON WHAT THE
TRUTH WAS.
AND SO THEY MPED THE GUN
YING TWITTER'SOING TO GET SO
MUCHORSE.
RST OF ALLHOW COULD  GET
WOE.
D IF YOUE ON TWIER A LOT,
AGREE, THEREOT BAS
CH -- I HAN'T SEENNY OF
THE BOTS
I VE SEEN LOT OF ADS.
I NEVER US TO SEE ADS D NOW
I HAVE ALL THESE ADS AND NOW I
BOUG THREE THINGS PERC
MY D, WITHIN A WK, INCLUDING
A TOTHAT APPARTLY MAKES
ISE  CAN HEAR T I CAN'T
HEAR WHI I THI IS A NIUS
TOSO MAYBE TTTER A ARE
ACTULY THE SOLUTION.
>> Greg: THAINTERESTIN
A TOY THATNLY DOG COULD
AR.
>> Da: YEAH.
GET IT?
>> Gre YES, I DO.
I WOULCALLHAT A DOG WHISTLE.
>> Dan OH, AND HERE WERE
CK TO THAT>> Greg:ACIST.
SEE, THAS HOW U DO IMISS YOUBEA.
>> Guy: I'M SOY, YOUAN'T
DECIDE WHI YOU PFER.
I HAVE SO MA INSHTS  THE
TOPIC T RST GREG I WAS
WATCHI YOUR SHOW LT NIGHT AS
A TTER OF FACT.
>> Greg: Y.
>> GuyAND I HAVE TO EAR
AIR ON SOMETHING.
>> Greg: OKA
>>uy: U, IN FRONT
LLIO OF PELE, COMPLAED
REPEEDLYHAT YOU WERE N
INVITETO MCHRISTMAS RTY
AND IN FRNESS IT IS BULOUS
AND GREAT AND IT'S TRUYOU RE
NOT INVITEBUT, BUT THIS IS WHY
I DETE IT D I SAID TS ISNOT THE
USUALLY ASKI ME TONVITE HIM
TO F EXALE THE LAST TI I
INVITED HITO A CHRISAS PARTYI H
OR.
YOU MEMBER WHY.
I SA THIIS NOT WHAT WE MEA
WH I SAID DONEE NOW OUR GAY
APREL.IT'S NOTPPROPRIATE.
XT YR YOU WILL BE INVITED.
>> Greg: I'LL BE BUSY
>> Kat: WLD NEVER G
I'VE KWN YOULMOST AN DECADE.
HOW NY OF  BIRTHDAY PART
VE YOU BEEN TO
'S AN SY NUMBER TO REMEMBER,
IT'S ZERO.
INVITE HIM IS NOT LIKE HE'
GO EITR WAY.
>> Gg: YEAH, JUST VER THAT
BASE.
>> Guy: YOWANT THE INVITTO
THEN DECLINE.
>> Greg: YXACT.
Guy: MY NEXT INO ON THE
OW WILL BE HE INTEME TO
S STUPID PARTYND I SD
WEOME Y BENSON.
>> Greg: ECTLY
HOW RE Y DEPRIVE ME OF THAT.>> Y
IR ENOUGH.
Greg: DO YOU VE AOINT TO
MAKE
>>uy: .
>> Greg: OKA THAT'S OL
BECAUSE WEURNED  SOM
MITES HERE.>> Guy: I'LLROP THPA.
I'LL DP E CHRISTS PARTY
AND LL SAY I'M ALL F
CLEANING UP E CHD PORN
PROBLEM ON TWITTERGO FOR IT ELO.
>> Greg: TRE YOU GO.
YOU' TING A BIG RISK.
>> Guy: THK YOU.
M GLAD THAT GOTTA WS.
>> Greg: KATWHY DO LIBERALS
DEND CHILD PNOGRHY?
KatI HAA WONDERFUL TI
AT THEARTY.
>> PROBLY E BEST ANSR
ATUESTION
>> KatSHUTP.
I'M T SU THAT THEY D
>> Greg: A YOU DEFDING
LIBELS TT DEFENDHILD
RNOGRAPHY, KAT?
>> K: OHGEEZ.
>> Tyrus: W WATHE PARTY
>>at: IT WAS SO MUCH F.
AND THEN IKEPT GETTING MORE
FUN.
YE, AND THEN I THOHT IT
CODN'TET MORE FUAND THEN IT DID.
LOOK, THIS SFF IOUT OF
NTROL.
I'VE ALREADY SN ONE LIBERAL
ACTIVIST OANIZYPE PERSON
SAYINGHAT MUSKALKING ABOUT
IS SFFINCITING VIOLEAGAINST BAK
KatDO THESE PPLE HEAR
EMSEES.
YOU N'T POINT OUT SOMETHING
WHO YBDID METHING ONG OR
DID SOMETHG QUESTIONLE
WIOUT CITING VIOLENCE
AGNST THEM.
BECAE, BY AT SNDARD,HEN,
DOING TT, YOU'RE CITING
VIOLCE AGAINST YOUPEOP, GO
WN YR FE, ERYTHINGAD
YOU' SAID OUT ANYBODY U'RE
INCITI VIOLEAGAINST EM.NOBODY B.
>> Gg: IT'S TRUE.
THEY'RE TING ATHOUGH, SEE
MOTHER JOAN THE MOST LEFT NG PU
LAWYERS THGH HE'SOME
FRAGILE TTLEELLY BEAN.
RUS?
>> Tus: YEAH, I KNOW A LOT
ABT AGILJELLY BEANS.
>> Gg: IJUST POPPED IN M
AD.
BUT,O, WHAT'S YO TAKE  ALL
THIS
>>yrusIT'S JUST LIKE Y
THAT REALLY CO BS, Y
DI'T HAVE THE CLK IN, CAME
TO WORK WHEN YOU WAND TO.
NOHE GONE AND THERS
SOONE -- THERE'S A NEW BOSS
TOWN AND HE'S MANG YOU ACCOUNTAY
DO YOUR WORK AND THAT'S WHAT ALL
TH ARGENT ISBOUT.
THEY DON'TARABOUWHETHER
ILD PORNRAPHY IS BEI STOPPED.
THEY CARE OUT E FACT TT
THEYE NOT ABLE TO CONTROIT.
EY WOULD PROBAY WAIT UNTIL
THERWAS A GO TIME TO GO IN
TRYING TSTOP CHILD
PORNOGRAPHY.
SHLD HAVE BEEN T FIR THING
ONHEIR MIND.
BUT EY WOULD WT UNTIL THEY
T IN TROUBLE AOULD
SUDDLY GO ON A CSADE TO OP
IT.
BUT EY C'T DO ATOW
BECAUSE THE BO HAS ONED UP
HE HAS MADE ITREE HE'S GOI
TER ACTUALEALLBAD PEOPLE
AND THEY DON'T LIKE RELY RL
INGS, THEY LIVIN THAT
EXTEOR, I DON'T THK TH
ITE KNOW WHAT CITED MEANS.
IF J BAKER H BROKEN GLSES
AND BLACK EYE YOU COD SAY SOMEOT
HIM.
BUT EY JUST SAY THINIKE
WHE'S THE OLENCE AND THE M
AND THE PELE ROCKINGIS C
YINGO PULL HIMSELF O.
NE OF THAT HAPNED.
IT'S LE INCITED, RACISM,EAL
PRLEMS.
TH DON'T DEAL IN ANY OF IT
THEY JT SAY IT AND EVERYONE'
LIKE OH.
AND THEN BEFORE OEVESAID IT
WOULD VE BN CANCELLED.
NOW THEYE T.
IT'S RLLY FRUSTRATING R
THEM.
>> Gg: TT'S UE.
>> Tyrus: THEYOSTHEIR ST
FRIEND AND BIG BROTHER, DIDN'T
HAVET THR WA>> Greg:RETTY SURE
TTING INTED TOIM BER'S
PARTNEXT YEAR.
>> Tyrus: I N'T GET ON YOU FORT
SAME THINGE DON'T GO.
>> Greg: EXALY.
Tyrus: YOU CAN INVITE US TO
WHATEVER.
>> Greg: WE' NOT GOING TO GO.
>> Tyrus: TO BE CL